this is a production of Cornell
University
thanks Tony
it's really good to be back at Cornell
and back in a my home department our
section now province soil and crop
Sciences so thanks everyone for being
here and today like Tony said I'm
sharing results from my dissertation
which I completed last summer looking at
vasive plants and white-tailed deer so
to begin with I just want to thank my
committee Dave Mortensen Erica Smithwick
were my co advisors at Penn State and I
had a lot of help with this project feel
lots of field assistants to several
contributors of data a lot of scientists
in the region shared their large plant
community datasets with me so I'm really
grateful for those contributions and
also for oh this might be advancing
automatically and also for the other
support I received at Penn State both
funding and and otherwise so invasive
plants are associated with a lot of
changes both at the eco the ecosystem
level and within the plant community
such as altered plant animal and
microbial communities biodiversity is
often associated with plant invasions
and ecosystem processes can can also be
influenced apologizing for this
advancing let me just switch this
present presenter view
if I can okay let's go back here for a
second so although all of these changes
are occurring alongside plant invasions
we don't necessarily know that clients
are the drivers and so the question is
whether other processes such as changing
disturbance regimes or alter community
assembly factors such as landscape
configuration and deer browsing might
actually be the ultimate drivers causing
ecosystem changes associated with often
associated with invasive plants so dear
quite abundant and for example at Valley
Forge the current deer density is 84
deer per square kilometre and this is
several orders of magnitude higher than
pre-european settlement deer densities
which were often less than 10 deer per
square kilometer often around five and
in nearby areas in Ithaca actually the
there are about 100 deer per square mile
in certain places of deer populations as
many of you know are quite high and they
can have big effects on plants
especially in forest under stories where
where deer take shelter and you can see
in this Ohio forest a very strong browse
line as a result of heavy dear pressure
so this can reduce the number of shrubs
and herbs enforced under stories causing
impacts on other animals that rely on
those species for habitat and also this
can create a window of opportunity for
invasive plants and indeed there are a
lot of examples of plant invasions and
forest under stories such as this is
Japanese Barbary in Connecticut garlic
mustard which many of you are probably
familiar with our yearly poles of garlic
mustard in the Finger Lakes and Japanese
still grass this is in the south south
eastern New York and this this grass and
the others are potentially facilitated
by selective dear browsing so why are
there so many deer across the landscape
and to show this I just want to give you
an idea of how the landscape has changed
since pre-european settlement currently
there's a lot of agricultural cover
whereas there used to be large
contiguous tracts of forest so in the
yellow here you see agricultural lands
the red and the pink indicate developed
land cover whereas the blue and the
green are much less apparent in these in
this map yet that used to be the
prevailing land cover across the
landscape so dear are responding to this
change in landscape configuration
because the foraging quality is much
better along forest edges and in open
habitats including crop fields deer can
be quite problematic in both soy and and
in corn even and especially in cover
crops deer can cause quite a quite an
impact in addition invasive plants are
also responding to changes in landscape
configuration so especially over the
last century both deer and invasive
plants have basically gotten a huge
advantage by the effects that humans
have had on changing landscape
composition and configuration so broadly
my research falls into the overall
overarching field an ecology of
community assembly and what I'm showing
here is the three major selection
factors that go into determining the
local plant community so first plant
species must disperse and move to a
certain location and then they must
tolerate the environment there so they
must have a physiological tolerance for
that site and then within the ecological
species pool these species compete and
also must cope with natural enemies such
as deer in the case of plant communities
and only then will the local plant
community be realized so I'm focusing my
research in in this area where I'm
looking at the effect of deer on on
plants so spatially deer are responding
to the landscape by choosing which which
landscapes and communities offer the
best foraging opportunities and also
weighing those against other
requirements they have for finding mates
and shelter so my research today I'll be
sharing occurred at three different foci
so the first part of my work is at the
low plant community scale at the plant
community level where I looked at
unfenced and fenced plots from across
the region and i'll be showing you those
results first then I zoomed in to look
at the deer to look at whether dear
preferences are helping to explain plant
abundance patterns that are occurring in
plant communities across the region and
then lastly I step back to consider the
context of landscape in the effect of
deer on introduced plants so first
across the region what are the effects
of deer on introduced and native plants
at the community level so first i want
to show you an example of a fenced and
unfenced plot this is a fenced plot on
the right and you can see a very clear
dividing line and this slide better than
the other and I have to say this deer
has been superimposed I just burn for
illustrative purposes
but in the plot on the left you notice a
lot of Japanese still grass and this
plant has grown almost all the way up to
the Fed the fence edge and then it
completely almost completely stops in
this case there's hardly any Japanese
still grass occurring inside the fence
where deer have been excluded so this is
a really striking difference in the
plant community composition and
structure and it appears that deer
browsing their selective browsing might
have facilitated the invasion so how my
dear facilitate plant invasion again
they're very selective browsers they
browse only species they find palatable
and avoid other species which then gain
a competitive advantage in the plant
community so the effects of deer include
changing competitive hierarchies in the
plant communities and this can have the
result of limiting forest understory
diversity and creating windows of
opportunity for exotic plants to invade
again there are ecosystem processes that
are influenced and the decreasing
stability and some of those processes
can again invite plant invasion so some
studies have already looked at the
effects of deer on invasive plants
showing that in many cases dear increase
plant invasion such as by increasing the
cover of garlic mustard and Japanese
still grass however at other sites there
have been no effects or conflicting
effects within studies such as at one
site multiflora rose was increased in at
another site which happened to be older
it was not the same pattern so the
really interesting study is that in some
cases in this particular case dear
decreased oriental bittersweet oriental
bittersweet is another invasive plant
and it appeared that deer presence
actually decreased the abundance so my
work aims to bring clarity to some of
these equivocal results in the
literature and also to more broadly
understand the role of deer in plant
invasion across the region whereas these
sites these studies only used one or two
sites my intention was to use sites from
across the region so this is a map of
those of those 24 sites and I collected
data at these two sites in northwestern
Pennsylvania but again like I said most
of the data sets were contributed by
other scientists in this first part of
my work i hypothesized that deer would
alter plant community composition and in
doing so they would facilitate plant
invasion and of introduced plants and
reduce the abundance of native plants
diversity and abundance of native plants
so the data comprised 200 of 229 paired
plots so that's a total of 458 plots
across the 24 sites and although the
experiments varied quite widely in the
purposes for the experiment in the first
place and the duration all of the sites
and had in common that they had fenced
and unfenced plots not sure what's going
on here sorry about that so the
commonality was they all had Benson
unfenced plots and they all measured
woody and herbaceous vegetation so again
the data sources varied the duration of
the experiments varied but I'm
controlling for that as you'll see with
a random effect approach so using data
from lots of different sources can be
very unwieldy and this was a really big
challenge particularly in that different
abundance plant abundance metrics were
used
across the the 24 data sets at 14 sites
stem density was used to estimate plant
abundance whereas and many other sites
cover was used or cover classes or cover
classes so this is an example art of all
of them let me mute this ok we have some
background noise so the these are the
cover class is used across the data sets
and as you can see they've really varied
from experiment to experiment so I tried
to combine all of the abundance metrics
into whoa boy yeah I might might be a
back issue gather windows do I want to
do that
okay so moving on to the data analysis
so to look at plant community
composition I used an indicator species
analysis and this determines the species
that are associated with certain
treatments so in my case I'm looking at
the species that are associated with the
deer treatment plus dear the control
plots and without deer in the fence
plots and to look at species and
community levels i used mixed model
analysis of baron variants and looked at
both plant species and community levels
though today I only have time to talk
about that plant community level in
addition to community composition so
just briefly I used fix the fixed
effects as deer but the random effects
were plot pair and site so I'm
controlling for the within sight
variability as well as between site
variability and the between site
variability i think is where a lot of a
lot of the noise might come in if i
wasn't controlling for those as random
effects so at first in summary about 700
plant taxa were recorded a cut across
the 24 sites 383 of those were native
and 111 were introduced plants and
there's a big gap there you'll notice a
lot a lot of the species unfortunately
over 200 could not be identified down to
species level so that's it's a little
bit unfortunate but I think that tells
us to a certain degree where the state
of our texana me expertise lies in going
out and collecting this data
unfortunately that occurred but I'm
focused on focusing on the species that
we could identify due to the level of
either being introduced or native and
about 18 species were present in plots
where deer occurred two additional
species were where a parent were
occurring where deer were excluded on
average
and those were native species you'll
notice that there were about three
introduced plants whether deer were
present or not and interestingly a lot
of taxa were only occurring where deer
were present or absent so fourteen
percent of the seven hundred taxa
occurred only where deer were were
present not occurring where deer were
excluded and then similarly eighteen
percent of the species occurred only
word to you were absent so I'm beginning
to show you the differences between dear
no dear plots and you can already see
that do you have a very big impact on
plant community composition so first
here I'm showing you the indicator
species analysis results and I'm
beginning with the six species that are
six introduced species that are
indicators of deer presence and you'll
notice that three of these six are
considered highly invasive and they're
also occurring across a lot of the 229
dear plots and across a lot of the sites
so these are some of the most widely
spread invasive plants in in the region
and at least enforced under stories and
the native speed there were several
native species associated with deer so
these are the species that you're more
likely to see across the landscape and
are more likely to persist despite hi
dear pressure and in contrast they're
occurring across many fewer of the plots
and sites so they're not as widely
distributed across across the region as
are the invasive plants and these are
some of the more frequent species oxalis
clear weed coral berry and singing metal
so these species are ones that I might
consider planting because they're
probably going to persist in the face of
deer better so as far as where deer were
excluded there were
five introduced plants strongly
associated with with that treatment and
again three of them happened to be three
are considered highly invasive and these
are Japanese honeysuckle bush
honeysuckle and multiflora rose and I
have a picture of a bird on a fence here
because the birds might be contributing
to the presence of these fleshy fruited
species inside fenced plots birds might
preferentially land on the fence because
it's a perch point in itself or within
the plants that are growing inside the
fence which are much vegetation is much
more dense inside the plots so there are
more perch points so that might be one
explanation why there are fleshy fruited
invasives occurring in forest understory
mostly forest understory plots so so far
I had shown six invasive plants that
were associate or three invasive plants
associated with no dear plots three
associated with plot with the absence of
deer but there are 27 native plants
associated with the absence of deer
suggesting that the natives are more
susceptible to deer browse than than the
exotic plants and these are some of the
more these are some of the more frequent
native species associated with the
absence of deer white ash spicebush
black cherry and even poison ivy
suggesting that deer might find these
species particularly palatable or in the
case of spice bush maybe birds are again
helping to disperse these species to
where deer have been excluded because of
additional perch points so overall we're
seeing big differences in exotic
introduced plants and native plants the
native plants appear to be more impacted
by deer than than the introduced plants
at the community level I'm seeing
similar results the introduced species
richness did not change whether dear
where President or
and a plant absolute introduced plant
abundance was also unaffected and this
corresponds to what I was seeing in the
indicator species analysis results
approximately the same number of
introduced plants are associated with
each of those treatments and there
happen to be three of each three in each
of invasive invasive plants however deer
had a big had a big negative impact on
native plant abundance and plant species
richness decreasing so dear decreased
native plant abundance in all three of
the abundance metrics and again this is
reflecting what I was showing in the
indicator species analyses total plant
species richness and abundance also
declined and mostly that was due to the
native plants so there's a difference
here in how dear impacting exotic plants
and native plants and it translates to a
proportional decrease or sorry a
proportional increase in the invaded
pneus of plant communities so the
proportion of introduced plant cover and
midpoint is higher where deer present so
even though Dearden influence the
absolute abundance of exotic introduced
plants they're increasing the relative
abundance of introduced plants so
they're increasing the degree of plant
invasion or in other words the invaded
pneus of plant communities this wasn't
the same for plant stem density and one
explanation for this is that deer might
increase the foliage on a plant but not
necessarily kill the stem so the stem
might persist even though the overall
cover of that individual stem is is
reduced so there's a bigger deer effect
on cover than on stem density might be
one way to interpret this so revisiting
that iPod
disease that I first laid out for this
this particular part of my research I
did find that dear alter plant community
composition and a couple caveats and in
the second hypothesis dear facilitated
the invasion of some species and at the
community level they increase the
relative abundance of invasive plants
not absolute abundance and lastly there
were definitely reductions in native
plant diversity and abundant in the face
of deer so my next question is whether
dear preferences can help explain some
of these patterns that I observed across
the region so that's the second part of
my research I'm just going to show you
show this briefly I won't go through it
all but please ask me questions about
this particular project because this was
a really interesting and unfun
experiment I set up dear preference
trials at the deer deer pens at at Penn
State where they have captive deer and I
use 15 different plant species offered
to the deer and a cafeteria-style
multiple choice preference trial so I
used introduced species and native
species some that were expected to be
palatable others that were expected to
be unpalatable for both groups and I'll
show you an example of the feeding let's
see if this video will work they didn't
always feed at the same time but there
were always two deer in the pen they
were too scared to be in a pen alone as
it turns out so they didn't have regular
feeding you can see them eating
blackberry here and honeysuckle here
honeysuckle turned out to be one of
their favorites surprisingly
so I'm showing you the results here
based on the ELA and an eel activity
index which takes into account the total
amount of biomass offered within each
trial and the amount of biomass offered
for each individual plant and it takes
into account how much was eaten of each
species relative to the other species so
a positive value indicates that the deer
preferred that species zero indicates
random feeding or feeding and proportion
to that amount offered at zero indicates
the plant was avoided so here i'm just
showing the overall results and you can
see that the invasive introduced species
on average tended to be more avoided
than the native species which especially
in a spring where more often selected
than the invasive introduced species but
there was an interaction at the level of
season and species so i'm showing here
the results the same results but with
species you'll see the 15 species that i
included in the trials on the bottom and
within each group invasive and native i
saw an increasing i saw quite a quite a
range of plant palate abilities and deer
preferences for these plants and i've
arranged them here according to deer
preference within each group i could
talk a lot about deer preferences and
that particular plant traits but i'm
just going to focus on the most
preferred and the most avoided species
so Bush honeysuckle european privet and
oriental bittersweet were the most
preferred species and again you'll
notice these all have fleshy fruits and
of the native species red maple was a
little bit of a surprise to find that it
was the most palatable of the natives
but there in the literature there have
been suggestions that it's not that
palatable of the species but again this
is all relative to just these species
that I included in the trials
and the deer were not starved just so
you know they had plenty of hay and
regular food but so these were all
somewhat of treats given they were given
an opportunity to have some some real
plant material not just hay and pellets
so of the species that were avoided
Japanese stilt grass garlic mustard and
Japanese barbary were highly avoided and
it seemed that based on some additional
data we collected bit of the behavior
dear behavior feeding behavior it was
quickly note the deer quickly learned
that these species were wants to be
avoided and this might explain why in
the across the region we were seeing
that these species increase in the face
of deer they're unpalatable they're
avoided relative to other species so
they gain a competitive advantage in the
plant community and of the native
species hey scented fern was the least
palatable and this is interesting
because it it's a species that has been
noted as a native invader and this is
one of the 24 dear research sites this
is in northwestern Pennsylvania where
you can see the fenced plot kind of
tried to outline that on the Left where
there are a lot more plants shrubs and
yet where deer are occurring there's a
lot of pace ended fern there are no
introduced plants at this at this site
but there is a lot of hey scented fern
so I think one point we might take from
this is that deer can cause an increase
in a plant species whether it's native
or introduced if that plant is
unpalatable so the unpalatable ax t
seems to be more important than the then
whether the plan was introduced or not
so dear are making choices the species
level not at the level of introduced or
native so just to sum up this this deer
preference section yes dear feeding
Frances can help us understand what's
going on in the plant communities across
the region as far as plants that
increase or decrease in the face of deer
and deer preferences very the species
level not at the native introduced level
and the process of plant invasion can
really be informed by understanding the
processes going on with this very small
patch level so at the in this last part
of my research I just wanted to share a
little bit of my findings based on
interactions that are occurring between
deer and landscape configuration so dear
aren't interacting with plant
communities in a bubble there are other
factors going on surrounding these sites
so what is the importance of deer given
the context of landscape fragmentation
so I'm stepping back here looking at the
landscape scale and what do I mean by
fragmentation well first it can imply a
loss of habitat changing landscape
compositions such as forests being
replaced by AG or developed land cover
and also it fragmentation and pride
implies broken apart landscape patches
such as a decrease in patch connectivity
and increasing edge habitat which I
mentioned is something that facilitates
both deer and invasive plants so briefly
these are the metrics that I used to
describe landscape fragmentation both
landscape structure and landscape
composition metrics I think I should
move on not talk too much about this
right now but again dear and invasive
plants are responding to landscape
fragmentation and it seems that because
deer were shown to have impacts on plant
communities across the region that this
is something we should really consider
what's the what's going on surrounding
the sites so I patha sized here that
both landscape attributes and deer would
jointly
influence plant invasion and high deer
density not just your presence or
absence which I only focus on in the
first part of my research will increase
planned invasion so I used the data the
same data from the 24 dear research
sites each site had an independent
estimate of the number of deer per
square kilometre at each of the sites so
I use those data as well as national
land cover data which I and I used
minutes so I use many landscapes to
describe the surrounding fragmentation
at each of these sites for instance this
is the Ithaca land cover tile you'll see
the airport the mall and there's a deer
exclosure site located right here within
this within this landscape the pink and
a the red are developed cover as you can
see Cornell's down here near the edge
and yellow and brown represent the
agricultural land cover while green
represents forest did cover so this is
the whole range of landscape surrounding
the 24 sites and you can see they range
broadly in the amount of forested cover
agricultural cover and developed cover
some of them are much closer to centers
of human high human population density
and some are very isolated from the
influence of humans some of these sites
had no introduced plants that all others
had many introduced plans so I used
several different approaches to analyze
this data just going to focus on some
results from mixed models and regression
but I'll give you a summary of the
overall results ordination
visualizations helped me see that there
are multiple invasive plants occurring
at a lot of these sites and the sites
have or the the plots are much more
similar in community composition to
others within that site then across
sites so each of the
sites are very different implant
community composition as far as what I
found from random forest results this is
a regression tree analysis based
approach to look at the relative
importance of different factorable
zeeeee and i found that landscape
fragmentation metrics and native species
richness were more strongly associated
with plant invasion metrics then was
deer presence/absence so that tells you
something right there at the landscape
level perhaps the effect of deer is new
isn't as important and exotic species
richness interestingly was explained
largely by landscape factors but also by
native species richness and this model I
had very high r-squared value so leads
me to think that these three factors are
quite important in understanding the
number of species the number of exotic
species at a site however there in the
mixed model analyses there were
interactions among dear presence/absence
the fragmentation metrics and native
species richness so i'm going to show
you one example of that here overall as
agricultural land cover increases the
invasion in in this case it's the
percent of introduced stems or the
proportion of the stems that are
introduced increase with agricultural
cover so overall there's there's a
there's a positive relationship here but
within each of the sites the effect of
deer plays an important role this
interaction was significant between deer
and agricultural cover so at the sites
where AG cover is minimal mostly
forested sites we're seeing that the
number of introduced stems the
percentage of introduced stems is higher
than where agricultural land cover is
much
so there's a switch you see the white
symbols are greater than the great
higher than the gray symbols where AG
cover is low and the opposite where I
cover is high so what might be causing
this relationship one explanation is
that the invaders the invasive species
vary across this across this gradient
and indeed at these sites where deer
were present Japanese still grass and
garlic mustard worthy worthy invaders
whereas in the agriculture higher
agricultural land cover mate landscapes
these species Japanese honeysuckle and
multiflora rose are more abundant where
deer have been excluded and again I
think this might be a result of bird
dispersal these species are more common
along edges and an open habitats so it's
not surprising that the propagule
pressure of these species would be
higher in a landscape covered more by
agricultural and open open land and to
look at not just your presence absence
but also to make use of the deer density
data that was available I found that as
deer density increased so did the cover
of introduced plants and the percent of
introduced species this wasn't found for
all of the metrics that I used to look
at plant invasion but it was a
significant relationship here suggesting
that deer density does make it a
difference so overall in revisiting the
hypotheses landscape attributes and deer
present we're both important in
considering landscape configuration and
do your preference and deer presence we
can more fully understand what's going
on with with plant invasion and just a
couple final points here
the surrounding landscape composition
can help explain why some sites are
invaded and others are not and we get a
much better understanding of plant
invasion by considering the factors
going on at a landscape scale so in
conclusion dear increase the abundance
of several invasive plants but reduce
others deer are indirectly facilitating
plant evasion because of the major
decrease they have they have in native
plants and deer preferences are helping
to explain those patterns and then at
the landscape scale both deer abundance
and exotic plant or introduced plant
invasion are linked to the overarching
structure and composition of of the
surrounding landscape and invaders
differ according to both the landscape
and according to deer preferences so I
think considering both of these is is
really important understanding the plant
invasion process is strengthened when we
examine it in light of co-occurring
multi scalar ecological patterns and
processes such as landscape
fragmentation and increasing deer
populations so perhaps forest
fragmentation and deer browsing are the
ultimate drivers of a lot of the
ecosystem changes that we see in
association with plant invasion so it's
just I think important to think a little
bit broadly about whether it's really
the plants that are driving these
changes are they or are they just
passengers kind of along for the ride as
a result of other changes and lastly
managing invasive plants might be
ineffective unless we're also managing
for changes in landscape structure and
composition and the increasing deer
populations so maybe one way to ask a
final question is what's more desirable
having very little growing where there's
very clear browse lines and forest under
stories or how
introduced plants growing so of course
this is kind of an exaggerated either or
but I think because there's an awkward
window of opportunity in a lot of forced
under stories because of the high dear
pressure the result is having invasive
plants but maybe the invasive plants
have some are offering some services
that we've we've overlooked and Antonio
and I have talked about how that might
be a an interesting path to go down from
here on so with that I hope there are
minutes for questions but it doesn't
look like there are if anyone has
anything they'd like to ask me now or
later I'd be happy why are they yeah
I've thought about that a lot over the
year over the past few years and one
explanation is that they're typically
higher light environment species and
whereas I studied a lot of study to
plant communities and forest under
stories for the most part there might be
a difference there between highlight and
and low-light environments i think in
high light environments those species
tend to grow really quickly so they
might just be able to outgrow any of the
deer browsing that occurs in those open
habitats because i have noticed in
walking through fields even that there
is dear browse occurring on those
species but maybe it's just not enough
the deer don't want to eat a hundred
percent of their diet of one shrubby
invasive plant they can only eat so much
of of it
a dumb one of the issues of the pressure
is actually forest regeneration so our
lessons from your studies
yeah definitely I think the hi dear
pressure is a really big concern in
reducing the native the native species
that we'd prefer to regenerate the
forests instead it looks like there are
a couple exotic trees that might are
invasive trees that might be taking the
place of our native trees but yeah I
think it's my research really just
supports the the fact that tree
regeneration is a big concern native
trees just are at a disadvantage given
the really high deer densities wondering
in your analysis
so there was people in their coverage
I'm wondering in your analysis focusing
just on
yes yes I was just focusing on what's
going on in the understory although some
of the species were black cherry maple
and oak in in the understory but those
species were much more common where deer
were excluded
I didn't specifically look at light
environments yeah so the comments I was
making earlier anecdotal it seems that
highlight could increase certain
invasive plants but a lot of these
unpalatable species that are more common
such as a hit Japanese stilt grass and
garlic mustard are tolerant of low light
but I think they must have those anti
herbivore characteristics in order to to
persist even in the face of deer on your
first point there there have been some
studies showing that deer dispersing a
lot of these invasive plants including
Japanese still grass which was a big
surprise to me but definitely the fleshy
fruited species they're dispersing those
into the into the forest across the
landscape as far as which species to
plant and definitely put up a fence
around anything you find really prized
that's what we've resorted to
what were compared to what happened in
other down the West the CC different
basis because there and
but other decisions in
I'm just looking at the literature it
seems like my research is in support of
are congruent with a lot of the other
findings dear generally reduced the
palatable species increase unpalatable
species and if unpalatable species is
exotic it definitely garners more
attention and I think what my research
suggests and especially with the hay
scented fern there's other other
literature to to back up the hay scented
fern native invader kind of point so
yeah overall I think they're pretty
similar in findings one difference might
be if not just abundant herbivores are
considered but just herbivores in
general and herbivores in general
actually have somewhat different
patterns but with deer in our case
they're very very abundant so it's a
little bit of a different scenario when
you consider a highly abundant native
species such as deer but we can talk
more about that too great thanks we're
up thank you again Christine this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell edu